how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
dc dc is making some moves and there's a
lot of news happening recently so i've
been doing more dc videos and
yesterday we found out some major news
about wonder woman 1985
now wonder woman 1984 has been pushed
back a couple of times now but it
recently stuck
on the date december 25th of this year
2020
christmas day now a lot of people were
doubting this theatrical release day
considering the fact that a lot of other
studios are moving their movies back and
warner brothers themselves have moved a
lot of their movies back
also then there's been a lot of talk
that wonder woman 1984 could be headed
to hbo max
now director patty jenkins came out and
said a while ago that that's not
something that they were considering
but lo and behold last night it was
officially announced that on december
25th wonder woman 1984
will be releasing in theaters but it
will also be releasing on hbo
max and get this it's going to be free
to anyone who already is subscribed to
hbo max
that means if you don't have hbo max
it's only going to cost
15 to see this film right now it's only
15
a month for hbo max and after the month
is over you can just cancel it
so very different from what disney has
done with mulan
for mulan not only did you have to have
a subscription to disney plus but then
you also had to pay 29.99 to watch
mulan on premiere access but now it's
official even if theaters do close down
again they're still going to release
wonder woman on december 25th
of 2020 on hbo max and apparently
outside of the us it's going to hit
theaters where they're open
on december 16th so pretty awesome news
about wonder woman 1984.
but now of course the big question is is
black widow going to follow the same
direction
now i've actually been saying this a lot
but there isn't really any
reason why they can't release these
movies in the theaters and
on streaming at the exact same time or
even if they prefer
a couple of weeks apart i personally
think that this should be the strategy
for all studios moving forward during
the pandemic if
you can't afford to wait until the
pandemic is over release it in theaters
and
on streaming now recently disney ceo
did hint that they are considering
premier access for
other major films now of course when you
thank other major films we instantly go
to black widow it's been delayed for a
very very long time now and its release
date right now is currently
a year away from the original release
date now marvel and disney do have time
to make this decision since the movie is
supposed to come out in may of next year
however disney ceo bob chapac did say
that they are going to talk about this
more on the investors meeting on
december 10th of this year
so it looks like we could have some
answers in less than a month but it
certainly is looking like black widow is
heading towards a video on demand
release on disney plus premiere access
whether that's a loan
or with a theatrical release date as
well again there's really no reason they
can't do both
the only concern for the studio is of
course how much will the movie make
what's the best move for that
so awesome news wonder woman 1984
officially coming december 25th no
matter what if you're stuck for this
like i am let me know in the comments
down below and let me know what do you
think they should
do with black widow should it be video
on demand theaters
or both let me know in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe so
you stay up to date on all the latest
marvel and
dc news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a tony
stark funko pop provided by
heroeshideout.com
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you